to all the Halloween heads out there you
should probably start following Jamie
Lee Curtis social accounts immediately
they continue to be ground zero for
glimpses behind the scenes of the
anxiously awaited slasher flicks
Halloween kills and Halloween ends the
iconic scream queen who portrays Laurie
Strode in the Halloween franchise has
been quite busy on her socials since
Halloween kills officially kicked off
production in September 2019 so far
curtis's posts have largely been still
shots taken on the set or in her trailer
like this Instagram post which Curtis
captioned never-say-die first day back
in the battle for my life
it appears the spooky time of year has
the Halloween kill star in the sharing
mood though as Curtis recently took to
Twitter to offer Halloween fans a tasty
treat a 21 second video that marks the
first in motion look at Halloween kills
Curtis tweeted tis the season to start
screaming first look at all the mayhem
David has created for all of you
needless to say but it appears a bloody
bad time is in store for the strode clan
in the upcoming sequel to 28 teens
Halloween penned by David Gordon Green
Danny McBride and Jeff Fred Lee and
directed by Green himself 2018 s
Halloween served as a direct follow-up
to John Carpenter's legendary slasher
classic of the same name from 1978 set a
few decades after the events of
carpenters Halloween the 2018 movie
found Laurie Strode a little older a lot
grayer and so deeply traumatized by her
encounter with knife wielding psychopath
Michael Myers that she'd spent the
ensuing years drinking her pain away
while training herself and her family
for a second showdown with the one who
we've come to call the shape the
showdown indeed came in the blood
splattered madness of greens Halloween
when it happened Laurie and company
eventually trapped the murderous Myers
inside a burning house of course Michael
Myers isn't that easy to kill the
basement cage clearly didn't hold since
the grisly gang is back for a pair of
sequels that will end the saga of Laurie
Strode and Michael Myers now a couple of
weeks into filming Halloween kills is
the first
those expected sequels and if curtis's
teaser is any indication things are
heating up on set
like literally heating up as it appears
the Halloween kills team has already
shot Michaels escape from the burning
basement at one point in the video
Michael is seen standing on the porch of
Laurie's house fire ablaze behind him
with what appears to be a torrential
downpour or perhaps firefighters water
hoses damping the raging flames if
you're wondering what this video might
reveal about the horrors Laurie and her
family are facing and Halloween kills
well there's really not that much we can
glean from it as of the making of this
video
the plots to both Halloween kills and
Halloween ends are being kept under
wraps while green and McBride have both
been candid about their sequels bringing
an end to the Laurie Strode Michael
Myers saga
they have categorically refused to tip
their hands as to whether either
character will make it out alive or if
they'll both meet their ultimate dooms
clearly Laurie underestimated Michaels
mortality in 2018 Halloween as she did
on two separate occasions as a teen in
the original movie that means in the
coming sequels shall likely be forced to
reckon with the notion that her decades
of prep may have been for naught
we can only hope she's got a back-up
plan to deal with Michael for now all we
can really do is hope that David Gordon
Green and the Halloween kills and
Halloween ends crew are bringing as much
fire and fury to the sequels as they did
to the 2018 flick we'll get our first
look at those sequels in a little under
a year's time when Halloween kills its
theaters on October 16th 2020 with
Halloween ends arriving almost exactly a
year later on October 15th 2021 until
then stay tuned to looper and Jamie Lee
Curtis is social media accounts
evidently for updates on Halloween kills
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite horror films are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]